should i go green
should you spend the time effort money
to make your company a green company i
got a great question from one of my
youtube viewers love you guys corona
wrote in to say would you purchase
clothes clothes made from recycled
plastic bottles
or do you think customers would care
about these positive impact it has on
the world
so first of all that's cool i've never
heard of a of a clothing that's made out
of recycled plastic bottles that's
pretty funky
but here's my answer for you and for
anybody who's thinking about should i
introduce a new green initiative or a
new social initiative
when it comes to those kind of important
decisions for your business i always
approach it from a position of
doing it to do it instead of doing it
for marketing reasons
typically if you just look at the stats
you can charge 20 to 30 percent more if
it's green or if it has a social angle
there is a little bit of a premium that
people will pay if they know that there
is a social component to it
but i would never say do it because of
that because it's not going to be
genuine people will see through it if
you're doing something
only to try to make more money
people have a pretty high bs meter and
they're gonna see right through it so
what i say to you
is do it to do it do it because it's the
right thing to do if this is what you
believe in if you believe in in green
business and entrepreneurs have a
responsibility to make our world a
better place and this is how you're
going to do it if that's your belief
then you do it
regardless of the impact it's going to
have with your customers you do it
because it's the right thing to do
and if that's why you're doing it
customers will come on board and they'll
believe it and they'll want to be part
of the movement that you're helping
create
does that make sense
when you are
only marketing something because you're
trying to make money
customers won't buy from you i had a
great question like this a while ago
where uh uh forget the guy's name he had
a business where he wanted to give a
portion of the sales to help feed the
homeless
that are outside his office
and with an issue like homelessness
there's
there's a lot of controversy
people might say
i don't support the homeless because i
think they should go get a job and
others will say the homeless people they
need our help they need help to get off
the streets
and it's just the right thing to do to
give them a meal
and he asked you think this would help
build his sales
and my response was the same it doesn't
matter if it's going to help build your
sales don't don't do it because of that
because if you do it
and you're only trying to increase your
sales then people again will see through
it and they're not going to buy into it
they're not going to come to your store
but if you do it because you feel it's
the right thing to do and even though
some people might think
i don't agree with him with what he's
doing but you're doing it because that's
your stance and you believe in it and
you want to help these people out if
that's why you're doing it then go for
it
and your sales will increase
by the time my video came out he had
already started
and uh
and he's had great results he feels
better himself about what he's doing he
feels that his business
now has a greater impact in his
community
and he's out there helping feed the
homeless through his company
and it's resulted in more people coming
and spending more money at his store
so it's worked but it worked because he
was really committed to it and he
believed in it
so
if you're thinking about recycled
plastic bottle shirts first of all send
me one because i want to see what it
feels like
but two again make sure you're doing it
for the right reasons like anything else
in business you're doing it for the
right reason you're starting this
business for the right reasons to have
an impact you're doing it to do it and
if you do it for that reason money will
come
believe
those are watching
thumbs up below if you liked the video
thank you so much makes me want to do
more for you and i want to hear what you
have to think leave a comment underneath
ask me a question about your business
i'll make a video response i love seeing
those come in they really make my day
every day so thank you so much please
leave a comment and i'll see you soon
you